impfpflicht für das pflegepersonal
bayerns regierungschef söder bringt die
ins gespräch wegen geringerer ins
bereitschaft und ernst wird viel kritik
kinderrechte ins grundgesetz nach langem
streit einigte sich die koalition auf
eine formulierung vielen ist die aber zu
vage nichts vom tier soll in die pfanne
die aktion veganer januar wirkt für den
verzicht vegane produkte boomen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten die vom sport hat
norbert lehmann mitgebracht einen
schönen abend auch von mir
bundeskanzlerin merkel rechnet offenbar
nicht damit dass wir bald auf strenge
coroner regeln verzichten können es
bleibe hart bis ostern wird sie aus der
unionsfraktion zitiert unterdessen hat
bayerns ministerpräsident söder eine
neue diskussion zur impfpflicht für
pflegekräfte losgetreten
zu wenige ließen sich impfen obwohl
gerade in den heimen die gefahr für
ältere menschen besonders groß sei
insgesamt sind in deutschland bislang
knapp 600 89.000 menschen geimpft worden
wie viele pflegekräfte sich impfen
lassen wollen dazu fehlen belastbare
daten
manche heime sprechen von nur rund 20
bis 30 prozent
die politik geht aber davon aus dass die
bereitschaft noch steigt ähnlich wie in
der gesamtbevölkerung
patricia schäfer mal wieder hat markus
söder eine debatte angestoßen bayerns
ministerpräsident möchte dass über eine
impfpflicht für pflegekräfte nachgedacht
wird keine allgemeine impfpflicht aber
so wie der ethikrat ist an diskutiert
hat das sollte das so ausführlich
diskutieren wenn es so bleibt bei den
niedrigen impfquoten in dem höchst
sensibelsten bereich den wir haben
der alten- und pflegeheime dann macht es
sinn diese debatte zu führen wie wir
dort leben schützen können
der deutsche ethikrat schließt eine
allgemeine impfpflicht aus würde aber
eventuell für pflegende von
risikopatienten eine ausnahme machen
wenn es keine andere möglichkeit gibt
diese risikopatienten vor einer
ansteckung zu schützen
und ganz wichtig es müsste natürlich
sehr viel mehr wissen darüber geben ob
die impfung tatsächlich eine ansteckung
vermeidet viel gegenwind aus berlin
bundesarbeitsminister heil will
niemanden zur impfung verpflichten auch
nicht in pflegeheimen
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
schließt eine impfpflicht ebenfalls
kategorisch aus sowie alle parteien im
bundestag in der altenpflege selbst wird
sogar befürchtet dass eine impfpflicht
pflegekräfte dazu bringen könnte den
beruf zu verlassen
fürchte dass die mitarbeiter kein
verständnis dafür haben wenn jetzt
plötzlich mit einer impfpflicht quasi
gedroht wird wir brauchen einfach mehr
aufklärung mehr informationen und dann
wird auch glaube ich die
impfbereitschaft steigen laut einer
internen befragung von 2.800
mitarbeitern in heimen der bayerischen
caritas ist nur ein drittel zum impfen
bereit ein drittel will gar nicht und
ein drittel fühlt sich zu wenig
informiert die informationen oder auch
inwieweit ist der impfstoff schon
getestet wurde zum im moment einfach
noch ein bisschen zu wagen
bei den pflegekräften die sich bereits
haben impfen lassen steht vor allem
eines im vordergrund der wunsch wieder
zu einer gewissen normalität
zurückzukehren
jetzt ist zum ersten mal die
hochansteckende südafrika variante des
corona virus in deutschland nachgewiesen
worden
betroffen ist eine familie aus
baden-württemberg die aus südafrika
zurückgekehrt war
in halle an der saale wurde am
nachmittag erstmals in deutschland der
impfstoff des us-herstellers moderner
geimpft und zwar mitarbeiter innen der
uniklinik und der schwedisch britische
konzern astrazeneca hat als dritter
hersteller die zulassung seines corona
impfstoffs in europa beantragt eine
entscheidung fällt ende januar
zurzeit können ja medizinisches heim und
pflegepersonal geimpft und menschen über
80 werden doch nicht überall werden die
älteren angeschrieben sie müssen sich
selbst kümmern
was aber wenn die hotline überlastet ist
zum beispiel susanne freitag berichtet
im ford line saarland
drei tage haben alfred und elfriede
moore stundenlang in der warteschleife
gehangen
sie sind mit 80 im zielgruppe haben sie
ein wenig geduld ein wenig geduld
da geht mir schon das ist furchtbar
nervös aber was immer ist hilflos jeden
tag liest alfred moore seiner frau aus
der zeitung vor sie ist fast blind
das mit den terminen soll jetzt besser
laufen steht da es gibt ein
großverfahren und eine warteliste wird
auch zeit sagt alfred moore im
impfzentrum ein paar kilometer weiter
könnten sie problemlos 2000 personen
täglich durch impfen der impfstoff
reicht aber nur für 300 ein grund für
die hotline überlastung und das netz ist
nicht für jeden der richtige weg die
angehörigen sind gefragt das hat habe
ich dann zuhause internet
unsere tochter des für uns gebracht und
das ging sehr flott bei den muss hat
auch die tochter eingegriffen und einen
termin im netz reserviert bestätigung
per handy herr moore soll auf einen link
klicken ohne smartphone 546 als das für
mich so gut wie chinesisch dann zu und
wir hatten das problem mit der hotline
hat sich nun erledigt die moors bekommen
einen termin wann genau entscheidet das
los die über 80-jährigen und ihre
probleme mit den impfterminen mehr dazu
bei frontal21 heute abend um 21 uhr und
in unserer app ist eine reportage zu
sehen wie das abläuft im impfzentrum
schritt für schritt zum durchklicken
eine nachricht auf die manche eltern mit
kindern unter 12 jahren gewartet haben
die bundesregierung hat beschlossen den
zugang zu den kinder kranken tagen wegen
corona zu erleichtern
sie dürfen auch genommen werden wenn
schulen und kitas wegen der pandemie
geschlossen oder eingeschränkt geöffnet
sind und eltern ein betreuungsproblem
haben
pro kind wird die zahl der möglichen
kinder krankentage für jedes elternteil
auf 20 verdoppelt alleinerziehende
dürfen jetzt 40 tage pro kind nehmen
die regel muss noch vom bundestag
verabschiedet werden
bayern und berlin verschärfen ihre
corona maßnahmen bei hohen
infektionszahlen dürfen sich
berlinerinnen und berlinern nur noch 15
kilometer von der stadtgrenze entfernen
gelten soll das ab 200 neue infektionen
pro 100000 einwohner
momentan liegt berlin knapp darunter und
in bayern gilt ab nächsten montag die
öffentlichen nahverkehr und beim
einkaufen muss eine ffp zwei maske
getragen werden
seit jahren kämpfen verbände darum dass
kinderrechte ins grundgesetz kommen
jetzt sind die chancen gestiegen union
und spd haben sich auf eine formulierung
der einigt grundlage ist die
kinderrechtskonvention der uno von 1989
sie garantiert unter anderem das recht
auf bildung den schutz vor gewalt oder
das die interessen von kindern
berücksichtigt werden müssen
die frage ob kinderrechte vorrang vor
anderen haben war in der koalition
besonders umstritten genetischer 1989
eine party bei den vereinten nationen
die kinderrechtskonvention wird
verabschiedet die begeisterung schwappt
auch nach deutschland kinderrechte
sollen ins grundgesetz
doch die kinder von damals sind heute
erwachsen umgeschrieben wurde das
grundgesetz nicht das will die große
koalition nun ändern
wir müssen bei jeder entscheidung die
rechte der kinder im blick haben daran
ist sowohl die gesetzgebung gebunden
daran sind gerichte gebunden und daran
ist auch die verwaltung gebunden
artikel 6 des grundgesetzes soll ergänzt
werden unter anderem so die
verfassungsmäßigen rechte der kinder
einschließlich ihres rechts auf
entwicklung zu eigenverantwortlichen
persönlichkeiten sind zu achten und zu
schützen
das wohl des kindes ist angemessen zu
berücksichtigen
die opposition kritisiert dass er ein
viel zu kurz gedacht kompromiss er führt
nämlich nicht dazu dass kinder
tatsächlich rechte haben die eindeutig
sind die klar sind insbesondere dass die
beteiligungsrechte von kindern keine
rolle spielen sehen wir als linke
ausdrücklich sehr kritisch
beteiligungsrechte das heißt kinder vor
gerichten oder behörden bei
entscheidungen beteiligen
ob es sich um einen neuen spielplatz um
sorgerecht oder gar um sexualisierte
gewalt handelt doch darauf hat die
koalition sich nicht einigen können was
auch verbände kritisieren
es geht nicht nur um juristerei und
gesetze dabei das grundgesetz ist das
leitbild der nation
und wenn da unsere kinder mit ihrem
rechten fehlen dann stimmt da was nicht
mit für eine änderung des grundgesetzes
braucht es eine zweidrittelmehrheit in
bundestag und bundesrat die ist bei
dieser kritik nicht in sicht es ist sein
erster live auftritt nach dem sturm aufs
capitol us-präsident trump äußerte sich
vor seinem abflug an die mexikanische
grenze und verteidigte die rede vor
seinen anhängern als angemessen
inzwischen gilt als sicher dass
vizepräsident pence darauf verzichten
wird trump für amtsunfähig zu erklären
britta jäger donald trump auf den weg
nach texas er rechtfertigt die rede die
er vor der erstürmung des kapitals
vergangene woche gehalten hatte wenn sie
meine regel lesen haben wie viele leute
das getan haben zeitungen und auch das
fernsehen haben sie analysiert dann
denken viele leute was ich gesagt habe
war total angemessen gestern besuch von
vize präsident mike pence im weißen haus
von ihm verlangen die demokraten donald
trump für amtsunfähig zu erklären ihn
vorzeitig aus dem amt zu entfernen
doch nach einem wie es heißt guten
gespräch ist wohl klar pence hält
weiterhin zu seinem chef mit einer
gestern eingebrachten resolution wollen
die demokraten den druck auf penns
erhöhen
noch heute will das repräsentantenhaus
darüber abstimmen kaum aussicht auf
erfolg
und so werden die demokraten das
insgesamt zweiter
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen jump
einleiten die einzige offene frage ist
wie viele republikaner die amtsenthebung
nun unterstützen werden und wie viele
weiter ausreden finden und wie schon vor
einem jahr mit erklärungen kommen werden
warum sie ihre pflicht nicht erfüllen
können
der präsident auf gebracht das ist die
fortführung der größten hexenjagd der
geschichte das ist absurd absolut absurd
diese amtsenthebung verursacht große wut
er wolle absolut keine gewalt fügt ram
hinzu doch genau damit rechnen die
sicherheitsbehörden vor und während der
amtseinführung von joe biden demokraten
werden gewarnt vor 4000 bewaffneten
extremisten die das kapital um stellen
und ihnen den weg versperren
auch das fbi erwartet am kommenden
wochenende gewalttäter in washington und
in den bundesstaaten am 20 januar wird
joe biden vereidigt 15 1000
nationalgardisten sollen ihn beschützen
nach deutschland hier hat der frühere
audi chef rupert stadler erstmals im
prozess und manipulierte diesel
abgaswerte ausgesagt und dabei betrugs
vorwürfe entschieden zurückgewiesen
aus sicht der anklage hielt es stadler
ab september 2015 zumindest für möglich
dass nicht nur in den usa sondern auch
in europa dieselautos mit geschönten
abgaswerten verkauft wurden trotzdem
habe der audi-chef den verkauf gut ein
jahr lang weiter laufen lassen um den
umsatz nicht zu gefährden
in zwei wochen soll das urteil
gesprochen werden im prozess um den mord
am kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lübke
heute hat der anwalt der familie sein
plädoyer gehalten
er hält anders als die
bundesanwaltschaft stefan ernst nicht
für einen einzeltäter
vom prozess in frankfurt susanne santina
es war heute der tag der familie von
walter lübke in seinem plädoyer betonte
ihr anwalt wie schwierig es für sie
gewesen sei an mittlerweile 40
prozesstagen in die augen des
mutmaßlichen mörders ihres ehemanns und
vaters zu schauen
stefan ernst hat ihrer meinung nach aber
nicht alleine gehandelt
den mitangeklagten marcos beschuldigt
sie der mittäterschaft
die familie ist der festen überzeugung
dass ohne den angeklagten h diesem ort
nicht möglich gewesen wäre und dass die
beiden ihn gemeinschaftlich verübt haben
und damit gehen die nebenkläger weiter
als die bundesanwaltschaft die davon
ausgeht dass stefan ernst am ersten juni
2009 10 alleine war als er den politiker
walter lübke ermordete markus hasler war
psychischer beihilfe geleistet haben
unter anderem durch gemeinsames
schießtraining
aber keine mittäterschaft weil nach
unserer überzeugung nicht hinreichend
anhaltspunkte dafür vorliegen dass
markus hardt tatsächlich am tatort war
anders sieht es die familie von walter
lübke die die einlassungen von stefan
ernst vor gericht als sehr glaubwürdig
bezeichnete der hatte sogar ausgesagt
dass walter lübke in den letzten
sekunden seines lebens in die augen von
markus h geschaut habe plädiert hat
heute auch der anwalt von 8 mit
denn stefan ernst wird auch versuchter
mord an dem irakischen flüchtlingen
vorgeworfen
47 jährigen droht lebenslange haft mit
anschließender sicherungsverwahrung
gute vorsätze fürs neue jahr dazu gehört
ja meist auch bewusster essen und da
setzt seit ein paar jahren eine kampagne
aus großbritannien an wegen dörrie nennt
sie sich und funktioniert wie eine art
spielerische herausforderung wer
mitmachen will muss versuchen den ganzen
januar vegan zu leben
dabei helfen die macher mit täglichen
ratschlägen und ermutigenden e mails
auch immer mehr deutsche probieren es
aus was den supermärkten und unternehmen
hierzulande nicht verborgen geblieben
ist elisabeth schmitt simon korn hat es
den januar über probe veganer tierschutz
eine gesündere ernährung deshalb macht
er bei wie can you where i mit neben
gemüse kommen bei ihm auch fleisch
ersatzprodukte auf den teller hoffe ich
auch alles weil man auch glaube ich da
noch in dieser szene drin dass man das
noch ein bisschen braucht diesen ersatz
für das eigentliche produkt fleisch und
wurst aus erbsen soja oder weizen
proteinen der einzelhandel wirbt derzeit
mit zahlreichen wie gary produkten und
hofft auf fette umsätze ergibt in
deutschland wurden 2009 10 mehr als
26.000 tonnen fleischlose alternativen
gekauft ein jahresumsatz von 273
millionen euro
der korona shutdown hat den trend sogar
verstärkt die menschen haben mehr zeit
sich mit ihrer ernährung auseinander zu
setzen und müssen es natürlich auch weil
sie eben ja die gastronomie größtenteils
geschlossen war
wir sehen wirklich eigentlich eine vater
plum des mannes kann man sagen wenn die
produkte kosten oft doppelt so viel wie
herkömmliches fleisch oder wurst der
kunde zahlt oft aus umweltschutzgründen
trotzdem ist vegan nicht automatisch
gleich gesund wenn man auf zusatzstoffe
verzichten möchte wird dann halt schon
schwierig das richtige fleisch ist als
produkt zu finden was dann auch noch der
richtigen geschmack und die richtige
rezeptur quasi mit bringt also gesünder
ist mit einem großen fragezeichen
simon kunert will deshalb auch viel
selber kochen hat vor sich nach dem
januar weiter vegan zu ernähren
morgen die handball wm in ägypten da
gibt es nämlich viel aufregung ohne
allerdings denn im us team sind offenbar
18 spieler unter trainer positiv auf
komik 19 getestet worden
tschechien hat heute sogar wegen
zahlreicher fälle im team zurückgezogen
stattdessen ist nun nord mazedonien
dabei und auch beim ersten deutschen
gruppengegner cup werden sollen sieben
spieler infiziert seien
schon auf dem rollfeld bekommen die
deutschen einen vorgeschmack darauf was
sie in den nächsten wochen erwartet die
korona blase mit strengen hygiene
konzept das wird wahrscheinlich auch
nötig seien bei den berichten über viele
infizierte in anderen wm-teams sache die
natürlich jetzt zur falschen zeit kommt
überhaupt nicht hierher gehört natürlich
und wir sind ja froh dass bei uns bisher
alles alles gut ist und wir haben uns
dann bestätigt gesehen dass wir schon
vor der maßnahme in isolation angetreten
hatten und die isolation geht weiter ihr
hotel in gizeh dürften die deutschen nur
für die spiele und fürs training
verlassen dazu alle zwei tage ein corona
test es wird sich zeigen ob der
wm-spielplan in den nächsten tagen
weiter durcheinander gewirbelt wird
ski alpin weltcup slalom der frauen in
flachau lena dürr ist im ersten
durchgang aktuell zwölfter den zweiten
durchgang den übertragen wir von 20 45
uhr im live stream dfb pokal heute abend
das nachholspiel leverkusen gegen
frankfurt bayer in der liga auf platz
drei aber seit drei spielen ohne sieg
die eintracht im mittelfeld aber mit
drei siegen in folge
anderem gegen leverkusen vor gerade mal
neun tagen ihr letztes duell in der
bundesliga das hackentor von amiri zwar
wunderschön doch zu wenig für leverkusen
die eintracht effektiver eine niederlage
die bayern auf den boden der tatsachen
zurückholte das war so ein spiel war von
isaac das spielt man einmal im jahr
hoffentlich nur einmal im jahr weil das
war wirklich nicht gut
diesmal sollen die schüsse ins richtige
tor gehen doch war frankfurt zuletzt
gerade im pokal sehr erfolgreich wir
wollen einfach unsere phase mit nehmer
die positive phase auch die art und
weise wie wir spielen er ist könnte ein
harter fight werden harmonisch dürfte es
höchstens nach dem schlusspfiff zu gehen
der sieger der partie der trifft dann im
achtelfinale auf den letzten
regionalligisten im pokal rot weiss
essen und bevor wir jetzt aufs wetter
von morgen schauen erst noch einmal ein
blick auf das von heute
da gab es für viele nämlich eine menge
schnee selbst in tieferen lagen war es
zwischenzeitlich winterlich weiß
autofahrer brachte das vielerorts in
schwierigkeiten
dafür konnten sich die kinder statt auf
überfüllten rudel hängen in den
mittelgebirgen einfach am nächstbesten
hügel vergnügen auch mal schön und heute
nacht schneit es im süden morgen vor
allem im nordosten mit heftigen böen
mehr dazu gleich von katja huhn ist so
viele von uns für den moment bettina
schausten freut sich um 21 uhr 45 auf
sie im heute journal
und hier übernimmt morgen barbara
hahlweg wir danken für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und wünschen noch einen
gemütlichen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren die
kaltfront von tief dimitrios hat uns
heute im wesentlichen von nordwest nach
südost überquert in norddeutschland gab
es viel regen in der mitte und im süden
heftigen schneefall und hier am
alpenrand schneit es jetzt auch in der
nacht noch weiter
sonst sind etliche schneeschauer
unterwegs an der nordseeküste gibt es
sogar winter gewitter bei einem starken
bis stürmischen nordwestwind es bleibt
auf den straßen nach wie vor glatt bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus 3 und
minus 3 grad und morgen liegen die
höchstwerte meist zwischen minus 1 und 2
grad
nur im nordwesten und am oberrhein wird
es etwas milder bei 3 bis 6 grad
morgen gibt es neue kräftige schnee
schnee regen und graupelschauer zunächst
in mecklenburg vorpommern und schleswig
holstein
die ziehen im laufe des tages südwärts
machen sie sich am nachmittag auf starke
bis stürmische böen selbst im binnenland
gefasst und westlich der weser kommt
morgen ihr regen aus den wolken heraus
die schnee regen und graupelschauer
erreichen bis zum nachmittag dann auch
das erzgebirge derweil die schneefälle
im oberpfälzer bayerischen wald genauso
wie am alpenrand schon am vormittag
nachlassen und in den nächsten tagen
geht es winterlich mit weniger schnee
und mehr sonne weiter schönen abend noch